life levels all men death reveals the
imminent
a life spent making mistakes is not only
more honorable but more useful than a
lifespan doing nothing
do not try to live forever
you will not succeed
you are going to let the fear of poverty
govern your life and your reward will be
that you will eat but you will not live
home life is no more natural to us than
a cage is natural to a cockatoo
those who do not know how to live must
make a merit of dying
life does not cease to be funny when
people die any more than it ceases to be
serious when people laugh
the great advantage of a hotel is that
it is a refuge from home life
life isn't about finding yourself it's
about creating yourself
miracles in the sense of phenomena we
cannot explain surround us on every hand
life itself is the Miracle of Miracles
life would be tolerable but for its
amusements
[Music]
I want to be thoroughly used up when I
die for the harder I work the more I
live I rejoice in life for its own sake
there are two tragedies in life one is
to lose your heart's desire the other is
to gain it
use your health even to the point of
wearing it out that is what it is for
spend all you have before you die do not
outlive yourself
[Music]
alcohol is the anesthesia by which we
endure the operation of life
all my life affection has been showered
upon me and every forward step I have
made has been taken in spite of it
there is no sincere love than the love
of food
it is most unwise for people in love to
marry
the love of economy is the root of all
virtue
a broken heart is a very pleasant
complaint for a man in London if he has
a comfortable income
love is a gross exaggeration of the
difference between one person and
everybody else
the perfect love affair is one which is
conducted entirely by post
First Love is only a little foolishness
and a lot of curiosity
the fickleness of the women I love is
only equaled by The Infernal constancy
of the women who love me
marriage is popular because it combines
the maximum of Temptation with a minimum
of opportunity
there is no subject on which more
dangerous nonsense is talked and thought
than marriage
marriage is good enough for the lower
classes they have facilities for
desertion that are denied to us
marriage is an alliance entered into by
a man who can't sleep with the window
shut and a woman who can't sleep with it
open
every man over 40 is a scoundrel
an asylum for the saying would be empty
in America
the man with a toothache thinks everyone
happy whose teeth are sound the
poverty-stricken man makes the same
mistake about the rich man
better keep yourself clean and bright
you are the window through which you
must see the world
a Perpetual holiday is a good working
definition of hell
I thank God for it
animals are my friends and I don't eat
my friends
the test of a man or woman's breeding is
how they behave in a coral
she had lost the art of conversation but
not unfortunately the power of speech
human beings are the only animals in
which I am thoroughly and cravenly
Afraid
the power of accurate observation is
commonly called cynicism by those who
have not got it
when a man wants to murder a tiger he
calls it sport
when a tiger wants to murder him he
calls it ferocity
he's a man of great common sense and
good taste meaning thereby a man without
originality or moral courage
democracy is a device that ensures we
shall be governed no better than we
deserve
you use a glass mirror to see your face
you use works of art to see your soul
I have to live for others and not for
myself that's middle class morality
in a battle all you need to make you
fight is a little hot blood and the
knowledge that it's more dangerous to
lose than to win
foreign
if you can't get rid of the skeleton in
your closet you'd best teach it to dance
the frontier between hell and heaven is
the only difference between two ways of
looking at things
Americans Adore Me and Will Go On
adoring me until I say something nice
about them
we learn from experience that men never
learn anything from experience
beware of false knowledge it is more
dangerous than ignorance
success does not consist in never making
mistakes but in never making the same
one a second time
the possibilities are numerous once we
decide to act and not react
no one ever believes that the Bible
means what it says he is always
convinced that it says what he means
no question is so difficult to answer as
that to which the answer is obvious
what a man believes may be ascertained
not from his Creed but from the
assumptions on which he habitually Acts
youth is a wonderful thing
what a crime to waste it on children
choose Silence of all virtues for by it
you hear other men's imperfections and
conceal your own
I want to be all used up when I die
and climb to the highest Summits but he
cannot dwell there long
it's so hard to know what to do when
when wishes earnestly to do right
you'll never have a quiet World till you
knock patriotism out of the human race
the worst sin toward our fellow
creatures is not to hate them but to be
indifferent to them that's the essence
of inhumanity
censorship ends in logical completeness
when nobody is allowed to read any books
except the books that nobody reads
just do what must be done
this may not be happiness but it is
greatness
I dislike feeling at home when I am
abroad
why should we take advice on sex from
the pope if he knows anything about it
he shouldn't
while we ourselves are the living Graves
of murdered animals how can we expect
any ideal living conditions on this
Earth
capitalism has destroyed our belief in
any effective power but that of
self-interest backed by force
we don't stop playing because we grow
old we grow old because we stop playing
people who say it cannot be done should
not interrupt those who are doing it
a man never tells you anything until you
contradict him
men have to do some awfully mean things
to keep up their respectability
the secret to success is to offend the
greatest number of people
a little learning is a dangerous thing
but we must take that risk because a
little is as much as our biggest heads
can hold
science never solves a problem without
creating 10 more
beauty is a short-lived tyranny
a gentleman is one who puts more into
the world than he takes out
the golden rule is that there are no
golden rules
hell is full of musical amateurs
find enough clever things to say and
you're a prime minister write them down
and you're a Shakespeare
foreign
journalist has never had time to think
twice before he writes
[Music]
Liberty means responsibility
that is why most men dread it
what we want to see is the child in
pursuit of knowledge and not knowledge
in pursuit of the child
if there were nothing wrong in the world
there wouldn't be anything for us to do
property is organized robbery
silence is the most perfect expression
of scorn
only on paper has Humanity yet achieved
Glory Beauty truth knowledge virtue and
Abiding Love
a man who has no office to go to I don't
care who he is is a trial of which you
can have no conception
old men are dangerous it doesn't matter
to them what is going to happen to the
world
The Faults of the burglar are the
qualities of the financier
power does not corrupt men fools however
if they get into a position of power
corrupt power
a happy family is but an earlier heaven
no man who was occupied in doing a very
difficult thing and doing it well ever
loses his self-respect
all great truths begin as blasphemies
there's no satisfaction in hanging a man
who does not object to it
baseball has the great advantage over
Cricket of being sooner ended
an election is a moral horror as bad as
a battle except for the blood a mud bath
for every soul concerned in it
self-sacrifice enables us to sacrifice
other people without blushing
dancing is a perpendicular expression of
a horizontal desire
better never than late
the natural term of the affection of the
human animal for its Offspring is six
years
most people do not pray they only beg
things are not born they are made by
artificial hallucination
a Fool's brain digests philosophy into
Folly science into Superstition and art
into pedantry hence University education
there is only one religion though there
are a hundred versions of it
what Englishman will give his mind to
Politics as long as he can afford to
keep a motor car
cruelty would be delicious if one could
only find some sort of Cruelty that
didn't really hurt
the fact that a Believer is happier than
a skeptic is no more to the point than
the fact that a drunken man is happier
than a sober one
virtue consists not an abstaining from
Vice but in not Desiring it
we are made wise not by the recollection
of our past but by the responsibility
for our future
the minority is sometimes right
the majority always wrong
democracy substitutes selection by the
incompetent many for appointment by the
corrupt few
patriotism is your conviction that this
country is superior to all others
because you were born in it
I am a Christian that obliges me to be a
communist
we are the only real aristocracy in the
world the aristocracy of money
there are no secrets better kept than
the secrets everybody guesses
if all the economists were laid end to
end they'd never reach a conclusion
[Music]
the single best problem in communication
is the illusion that it has taken place
the first condition of progress is the
removal of censorship
imagination is the beginning of creation
you imagine what you desire you will
what you imagine and at last you create
what you will
Hegel was right when he said that we
learned from history that man can never
learn anything from history
my reputation grows with every failure
do not waste your time on social
questions
what is the matter with the poor is
poverty what is the matter with the rich
is uselessness
the heretic is always better dead and
Mortal eyes cannot distinguish the saint
from the heretic
assassination is the extreme form of
censorship
care to get what you like or you will be
forced to like what you get
when a man says money can do anything
that settles it he hasn't got any
foreign
is the same as communism only better
English
progress is impossible without change
and those who cannot change their minds
cannot change anything
an index is a great leveler
beauty is all very well at first sight
but whoever looks at it when it has been
in the house for three days
never fret for an only son the idea of
failure will never occur to him
perhaps the greatest Social Service that
can be rendered by anybody to the
country and to mankind is to bring up a
family
if you must hold yourself up to your
children as an object lesson hold
yourself up as a warning and not as an
example
I'm afraid we must make the world honest
before we can honestly say to our
children that honesty is the best policy
an Englishman thinks he is moral when he
is only uncomfortable
in heaven an angel is nobody in
particular
every person who has mastered a
profession is a skeptic concerning it
the only way to avoid being miserable is
not to have enough Leisure to wonder
whether you are happy or not
nothing is ever done in this world until
men are prepared to kill one another if
it is not done
some look at things that are and ask why
I dream of things that never were and
ask why not
the trouble with her is that she lacks
the power of conversation but not the
power of speech
I enjoy convalescence it is the part
that makes the illness worthwhile
there is nothing more dangerous than the
conscience of a bigot
I often quote myself it adds spice to my
conversation
he who can does he who cannot teaches
you injure your neighbor better not do
it by halves
until the men of action clear out the
talkers we who have social consciences
are at the mercy of those who have none
it is dangerous to be sincere unless you
are also stupid
one man that has a mind and knows it can
always be ten men who haven't and don't
the best place to find God is in the
garden you can dig for him there
everything happens to everybody sooner
or later if there is time enough
people become attached to their burdens
sometimes more than the burdens are
attached to them
men are wise in proportion not to their
experience but to their capacity for
experience
except during the nine months before he
draws his first breath no man manages
his Affairs as well as a tree does
few people think more than two or three
times a year I have made an
international reputation for myself by
thinking once or twice a week
Independence that's middle class
blasphemy we are all dependent on one
another Every Soul of us on Earth
Beware of the man who does not return
your blow
he neither forgives you nor allows you
to forgive yourself
we should all be obliged to appear
before a board every five years and
justify our existence on pain of
liquidation
give a man health and a course to steer
and he'll never stop to trouble about
whether he's happy or not
it is the mark of a truly intelligent
person to be moved by statistics
the Liar's punishment is not in the
least that he is not believed but that
he cannot believe anyone else
the only secrets are the secrets that
keep themselves
foreign
and thinks he knows everything
that points clearly to a political
career
statistics show that of those who
contract the habit of eating very few
survive
when a stupid man is doing something he
is ashamed of he always declares that it
is his duty
if history repeats itself and the
unexpected always happens how incapable
must man be of learning from experience
dance
nothing is worth doing unless the
consequences may be serious
Fashions after all are only induced
epidemics
smallest corner of your head vacant for
a moment other people's opinions will
Rush In from all quarters
the British soldier can stand up to
anything except the British war office
you cannot be a hero without being a
coward
a government that robs Peter to pay Paul
can always depend on the support of Paul
do not do unto others as you expect they
should do unto you their tastes may not
be the same
[Music]
reading me Don Quixote a gentleman but
believing what he read made him mad
which painting in the National Gallery
would I say if there was a fire
the one nearest the door of course
political Necessities sometimes turn out
to be political mistakes
the moment we want to believe something
we suddenly see all the arguments for it
and become blind to the arguments
against it
I learned long ago never to wrestle with
a pig you get dirty and besides the pig
likes it
peace is not only better than War but
infinitely more arduous
lack of money is the root of all evil
very few people can afford to be poor
if women were particular about men's
character they would never get married
at all
it is easier to replace a dead man than
a good picture
what is virtue but the trade unionism of
the married
I never thought much of the courage of a
lion tamer Inside the Cage he is at
least safe from people
without art the crudeness of reality
would make the world unbearable
[Music]
we have no more right to consume
happiness without producing it than to
consume wealth without producing it
few of us have Vitality enough to make
any of our instincts imperious
why except as a means of livelihood a
man should desired to act on the stage
when he has the whole world to act in is
not clear to me
[Music]
the things most people want to know
about are usually none of their business
syllables govern the world
in this world there is always danger for
those who are afraid of it
the people who get on in this world are
the people who get up and look for the
circumstances they want and if they
can't find them they make them
I never resist temptation because I have
found that things that are bad for me do
not tempt me
the truth is hardly any of us have
ethical energy enough for more than one
really inflexible point of Honor
martyrdom the only way a man can become
famous without ability
we must always think about things and we
must think about things as they are not
as they are said to be
I would like to take you seriously but
to do so would be an affront to your
intelligence
parentage is a very important profession
but no test of Fitness for it is ever
imposed in the interest of the children
virtue is insufficient temptation
if a man did not marry before the age of
30 this means that he has not yet met a
woman who would marry him men marry not
because they want a woman to marry but
because they want to get married
you can always tell an old Soldier by
the inside of his holsters and cartridge
boxes The Young Ones carry pistols and
cartridges the old ones grub
the man who writes about himself in his
own time is the only man who writes
about all people in about all time
the art of government is the
organization of idolatry
when I was young I observed that 9 out
of ten things I did were failures so I
did 10 times more work
[Music]